beautiful re thank you enjoy [__] hey
you said frig I wait a minute like to
propose a toast to my family
someday soon you're gonna have families
of your own and if you're lucky you
remember the little moments like this
that we're good
Cheers
you
I never stopped to worry about a thing
hoping
hey buddies this is steve Simone and
you're listening to good times and as
always I'm hanging out with my buddy Lee
hello Steven hey mr. Lee saya how you
doing ma'am it's been a full week yeah
it's been such a long week like
yesterday was the fourth of July and it
seems like forever ago we did that live
podcast but it was just a couple days
ago I know and it went great it was a
lot of fun did you have so much fun i
had pizza which i think it's called
pizza nice does a place it yeah it's a
nice to downtown i wanted to give him a
shout out it was delicious they use i'm
a pretty simple person when it comes to
pepperoni mm-hmm well i'm gonna come to
pizza all i really want is cheese and
pepperoni old school they had some spicy
pepperoni was delicious right and they
didn't use too much sauce oh really
perfect that's my favorite pizza and
then I don't know who brought though I
think you did but there are cupcakes
there and no I Bryce brought though
that's like a terribly I shake and your
buddy Ian who's gonna be on a future
episode yes I'd to get me to have one
and I didn't but they looked really good
and other than the food was all oh still
great night but just that those cupcakes
you up on stage dancing at one point
weren't you had to darin carter darin
carter called me when the party started
cold I'm gonna pull up there on Carter's
Twitter right now cuz he dad Aaron
Carter is that what it is that simple
i'm almost positive Eli can check for
him because he did such a I had one
mission in mind we need to get the good
times flowing oh yeah that's him and
there's only one person that can do that
he uh and I would never have done that
before so if you were there you saw it
if you if you if you weren't there than
you miss it you'll ever see it again it
was so much fun but it was it was so
great he he was a it's one of the
closing a book about podcasting is that
there's a lot of people doing live
podcast now and and you had a completely
different spin on it it was a lot of fun
yeah I wanted to make it a party
something fun and um I hope this week is
like fun i'm gonna be down in San Diego
hope that's fun I hope when you guys are
listening each episode is it like this
episode if you don't have fun listening
this I don't know what to give you up
because this is I felt bad that more
people couldn't make
it I mean we're here in Los Angeles and
I know people listen all over the world
so this this week we're going to
actually release the live podcast yeah
one with Roddy Piper which was amazing I
and for me especially when it's a topic
that I don't know much about if I if I
can still have a good time yeah then I
know it's fun like he was so funny yeah
he was great and and some people I know
because a lot of people have a lot of
podcasts to listen to someone might be
like oh I don't know wrestling so I'm
not gonna listen to it trust me listen
it you'll have a good time regardless of
whether or not you've ever heard of my
stories are banana yeah it was and I had
I had no the only one I knew about was
one you talked about a reporter and I
won't ruin it for the story but that's
the only one I had heard about in the
entire hour and a half or hour that you
guys did together and it was cool for me
to watch because I see the relationship
you and why haven't reminds me of what I
have with Joey yeah so it's pretty it
was just it was fun to watch especially
cuz you know you know Roddy you know the
stores and you can kind of lead him to
certain things if he's if that you know
are gonna be entertaining and fun for
everybody yeah like that's what I was
trying to do because he I think one of
the best episodes of good times we ever
had was his first appearance on this
podcast which I believe was week three
it was right at the beginning yeah I
think it was it's one of the first ones
i think it was week three and we just
had such an open and honest conversation
and i couldn't believe what Roddy was
that vulnerable and real with us right
it was so cool and then for this one I
wanted to sort of have that vibe of like
everybody's 11 years old again our mom
let us order pizza and some famous pro
wrestler can't buy to hang out and was
like story time with uncle Roddy it was
it was pretty grand everyone was really
respectful like it's it when it went a
good story like that's going on you're
not gonna get anyone talking her or were
being rude and it was just uh there's a
lot of fun to be a part of and then and
then you brought those like juice boxes
from from Satan like the all sugar ones
oh the little hugs I haven't had those I
haven't had a little house elevation
since yes it's like they're called
little hugs yeah the ones that look like
little plastic barrels yeah
I didn't know if they still made those I
thought they might have been banned
somewhere during the Reagan
administration for just being pure sugar
what are the ones of those that are like
someone's head like it's a bottle and
you twist off the top it's like a
plastic bottle it's not like a soda
bottle total wax bottle just filled with
but it's not waxed it's not tiny tonight
it's like a big bottle like kool-aid oh
yeah and you just and it's like plastic
but it's a weird kind of break the top
off yeah they're cool too well all sugar
water well somebody was like you should
get Capri Suns but then when I saw the
Hawaiian Punch version of Capri Suns had
to have that you can't beat those can't
be that plus pizza and was free free
pizza and drinks and there's a lot of
pizza later yeah I think God he needs to
killed it didn't all get eaten like all
of it like when I think autistic Thunder
probably had a whole large pizza by
himself next room he was killed loving
it and I was so happy you guys will hear
it too it just worked out perfect um our
buddy Josh who's been on the show before
I love him to death he was the only
audience Mikey was on his best behavior
cuz I know he wanted to ask a million
questions because before he was like can
anybody ask a question can we just shout
out questions like if Roddy's talking
can I just shout something out i'm like
Josh I don't think that's the best idea
I think maybe what we'll do is so try to
save questions for the end and I said if
there's something you want to ask grotty
I'll make sure you get to do it in
private it was like okay but then it
just worked out perfect where it was
like we had a little bit of time for
questions because they gave me the five
minute warning and it was Joshua that
got to ask his question and he got the
laugh of the night I thought yeah when
he told his story about first meeting
Robbie we'll just leave it oh no it was
it was a perfect right it was great and
Joshua is someone who's the nicer than
nice anyways but he really loves
wrestling so like he does it was it the
first time oh no when that wasn't the
first time you met Robbie but that must
be still be pretty exciting for him yeah
I think so I mean it's exciting for me
like that my friends get to hang out
with each other that's all that's the
best thing in life it really it's
amazing how was his fourth of July for
you it's wonderful um I went up to the
Rose Bowl for the
first time I've never been to the rose
blooming ever and it was great best
fireworks I've seen uh if I were example
oh the greatest oh that's so fun was so
much fun do you have to pay to get in or
how does it work you got to pay for
parking but there are ways around that
but I was glad we paid for parking
because it's just added to the
excitement and fun right yeah because
there was like oh my god there was the
cutest family right near us with little
boys that were like probably like two
and four I just kept on walking over to
me and they were playing and then they
were looking up and playing and like
they wanted us to get in the mix they
were so cute that's all so it was great
and uh oh you know what I did want to
say this I started a relationship with
Children's Hospital so if you're in the
LA area I want to give you their phone
number they need blood desperately so
there's nothing to be afraid of it's
doing the right thing it's going to make
you feel so good I really do believe
everybody wants to help out we just
don't know how to help out so here's
your way to help out if you live in LA
you can donate blood and you're not a
fraidy-cat just give give Children's
Hospital Los Angeles a phone call at 32
33 6 1 2 441 and actually our buddy
price designed some cards that went in
the goodie bags are for a net put
together oh yeah thank you bryce and
thank you not for all your hard work
that made Tuesday possible Thank You
pizza nista Thank You Inc advertising
for helping sponsor the event guys inc
advertising their bryce's buddies so
they're the people that did my new
stickers if you guys want new good time
stickers just hit me up at at Steve
Simone on Twitter or my facebook send me
your address I'll send you some stickers
because I got hooked up from Inc
advertising they do everything they do
t-shirts posters hats everything and
they'll give you a discount for being a
body a good time just give them a call
it 479 2748 337 and it's a real
mom-and-pop business their prices
friends yeah i'm i'm supposed to be
doing some posters printed up from them
oh that's awesome you know what Lea
you're wearing an awesome flying jus t
shirt you need to get those printed up
again half price his buddy
hook you up oh no he's elytte slits this
design as a poster huh no way so yeah
was I'm supposed to happen pretty soon
so that'll be fun and you're gonna have
him for Toronto hopefully that's the
whole point yeah I would love to I would
love to have everything for Toronto
which will be really fun yeah me too i
gotta get that plane ticket cuz i'm
supposed to go to philly in like 10 days
having a plane tickets are like seven
eight hundred bucks i know sucks that's
why i got mine in then i just found one
I'm trying to go to Boston in September
sorry I'm one that is it actually a
reasonable price awesome so what uh like
what are you gonna do in philly that's
me every time we go back yeah i was just
there which is great so definitely see
the family um Steve Byrne I think knows
this guy that owns one of the best
cheesesteak place has ever in the city
called Geno's and if I gets here just
the fact i think lujo that's hysterical
when you suggesting how can you how can
you not so I think burn knows that guy
and we might be able to sit at the VIP
table I'm gonna steal one of your waters
go for it cuz this coffee I track was
yuck oh speaking of good coffee guess
who's back who's Barry the official
sponsor we have to sufficient on sirs
the unofficial official sponsor which is
Don Carlos they never went away never
went away and Ryan I'm coming for you
this weekend I'm gonna be a la jolla
friday and saturday two shows each night
but friday night late show guess what
Lee what's happening you got to say it
like you're six what Steve guess what my
friend Gabriel is gonna headline so if
you guys jump on this right away you
might be able to get tickets and when
you said Gabriel me like Gabriel Stevens
or Gabriel no I mean the fluffy guy
himself mr. Gabriel Iglesias it's so fun
yeah I love that man so much like when I
think of like all the stuff i try to do
that's nice for people its people like
Gabe that keep me going like this simple
fact like I know how busy I am the
simple fact that i can return my texts I
don't know how he does it and I'm very
excited I get to hang out with them and
it's Comic Con weekends
and my buddy Jax is hooking me up with
passes I'm gonna get to go to comic-con
what are you gonna dress up as awesome
Steve calm you should just put a shirt
with an A on it and you're awesome Steve
why not I do think those girls that
dress up like the what do they call this
cosplay girl I think they're pretty oh
yeah of course they are so pretty oh so
this is the deal I don't I have to talk
to my buddy that knows the guys over at
craft coffee but I think they're hooking
us up with a very likable I guess you
guys are doing a good job with the good
times code word or whatever at Croft
craft coffee calm the way I look at it
is it's delicious treat that's
affordable and maybe because they've
heard the plugs I've given them on the
podcast I don't know if I don't know if
the owner the company's a one of our
buddies are not that listens he must
because this would he came up with
because remember I said it was rich
people coffee at normal people prices oh
yeah cuz that's essentially what it is
like they I think that the word is like
they they're almost like an art museum
that goes around the world cultivating
the best beans and they are the it makes
it really difficult to drink crappy
coffee and you're drinking this stuff
and most especially since I drunk my
coffee black so I just like to taste it
right sometimes I put a little little
bit of cold water or ice cubes if I can
to just make it a little more room
temperature okay so I drink it faster
but this stuff's amazing and what
they're going to do is you if you use
the the code word good times bag which
is this their hope if you think about it
good times bag you can get a bag of
their awesome coffee for 399 whoa yeah
that's incorrect I don't know how
they're doing that and then they're also
having a summer sale where they're doing
discounts for all new customers so if
you guys ordered before you can still
get a bag for 399 if you haven't ordered
before you can get a bag for 399 and a
discount on top of that but I think
that's only going to work for a week
this is like the let the cart places the
car dealerships to say we have a deal
i'd only yeah it's too good to see if my
lawyers knew I was saying this yeah yeah
but we're not legally allowed to say how
cheap it's gonna get but it's actually
like a real commercial you can actually
have a good deal like three nuh like how
much was that coffee that you bought by
disgusting all right that was the
interesting thing I wasn't even part of
my thought process this afternoon but I
called you I'm really tired from all the
shenanigans this week and we came in
here to do the podcast and then I was
likely do you want anything from
7-eleven and you're like now I have some
water here cuz you're killing your diet
you look great I'm trying but it's okay
i'm dragging ass right so I'm going am I
going to get a sugar free energy drink I
don't want to give them a plug and I was
like no I don't want those chemicals
that stuff's killing me so then I was
like what can I do and then I was
thinking of a diet soda I was like a
diet sodas better than an energy drink
cuz like if I will omit this like if I'm
at the comedy club or something I'm
hanging out at the comedy store I'm
gonna get a diet soda with no ice
because the way I justify it my brain is
I'm not drinking booze I'm not smoking
pot or what I'm just like this is my
little treat to get me going but the
problem is it's still poison and I try
to drink a little as little of it as
possible it is still boys and then I
need to drink a lot more water but
especially at a comedy club where untold
things are happening you have you having
a diet coke with no ice is pretty right
now Abby I know I know well that's why I
like but I was like I'm not gonna give
that up essentially that'll be my treat
and i still drink a lot of water when
i'm at the club yeah but so this
afternoon i was like will save the diet
soda for after the podcast cuz you have
to do a show tonight you're gonna want a
little pick-me-up before the show so as
i get a coffee i can't drink this piss
and it must have cost you at least 23
bucks right that cost me 169 right and
so an entire bag of coffee is gonna be
399 yeah buying in bulk is really like
the best deal for anything yeah I don't
know what but she's doing it at your
house the little one craft coffee hit me
up and they just sent me like their
little sampler like what you can order
every month they sent me three different
flavors of coffee and it was delicious
and it was fun it was like it was like
an activity and in to treat I love doing
packages and all it's so much fun like
makes me think when I'm a little kid
like we used to shake down the UPS guy
like bro are the fireworks coming or not
let's make it happen cuz we used to
order fireworks from Florida can order
them over the Internet not anymore oh
really this is back in the eighties the
magazine we would yeah we would buy
magazines depending on what ads were in
the back and we'd go okay buy this
magazine will send the way for the
catalog and I remember that there was a
place and I believe Pensacola Florida
that was called holiday fireworks and
they would you could get a gross of
bottle rockets 144 bottle rockets for
two dollars and fifty cents it's a
miracle you didn't blow up your house
miracle last night there was almost an
incident at your house yeah because it i
think i'm almost certain I've Lytton off
a lid off at least like one firecracker
a bottle rocket one piece of
pyrotechnics every fourth of july since
i've in 12 i I know I must have missed
some in there but I think I really have
or maybe just a few so anyway I wanted
to keep the streak going okay so I had
some skyrockets left over from last year
and I was with my friend that never she
never lit off a firework ever in her
life I think I've lit up when I get
actual legit fireworks oh mike wall
right well i know what we're doing later
tonight i'm picking you up and we're
light went off home down but what
happened last night oh so then i was
getting nervous because i didn't want to
get I didn't want the fuzz involved
either cuz like I don't like doing
anything wrong but I balance out I did
what was at war and the kids don't do
this la man adult so but you definitely
have to be an adult to light off
fireworks but it's not you're not
supposed to here in Los Angeles even
though a lot of people were and what I
did was wrong and then what happened was
I I'm very patriotic person like that my
highlight yesterday I was wearing one of
my USO shirts cuz when the last or did
they gave me a red USO shirt but had all
the flags of the countries in Southwest
Asia oh cool so when we were gonna walk
into the rose bowl cuz they charge you
13 bucks to get in okay so worth it you
don't then you don't have to pay for
anything by the way you can park further
away and just watch the fireworks but
parking spending the 25
the park and walking through all the
family fun I didn't feel like it was the
most family-friendly event I've ever
been to in Los Angeles or California for
that matter it was it was as American as
American gets and then for 13 bucks we
were as close we were only other because
they did a concert and motorcycle tricks
but we missed all that stuff yeah for
thirteen dollars so we had to sit all
the way at the end but guess what by
sitting all the way at the end we were
closest to the fireworks and the
highlight of the fireworks show I go
like this no way and there was a little
boy behind me like three maybe four and
he goes yes wait like that it was
adorable so anyway my highlight was I
was wearing my USO shirt and some guy
thought I was in the military maybe he
was like well if you're in the military
you get him for free and I was like now
I'm just a comedian he's like how'd you
get to shirt I was like I'm a comedian
I've done shows he was like well I'm a
Marine thank you so much for going over
there and entertain it like we made
friends on the fourth of July that's so
nice and always any part of you like
maybe i should say I'm in the middle now
it's always weird Gracie those videos
like so bad I don't know how people know
how does that even happen that gets into
someone's brain Louis low self-esteem
there's a lot of sad people out there
and I get it you know I don't judge
anybody like when people are like do you
really dumb things I just go thank God I
wasn't that done but what has I've
almost been that dumb does that make
sense yeah oh yeah I've done so many
stupid things in my life I don't want to
ever like last night lighting off the
fireworks so what happened so the angle
the rocket was already lit I had it in a
bucket but then it tipped a little bit
and it landed right in a tree and that's
where it exploded and I was like oh
that's it I'm going to jail I'm burning
down the neighborhood there's there's a
drought and I had to be a dumb
fourteen-year-old grown up any blew up a
tree mm-hmm but nothing thank God it
didn't catch on fire oh then go sweet
baby Jesus but like I did do the nerves
I went inside changed my clothes because
I remember that from middle school high
jinks and then just walked by from
another direction like
mm-hmm I wasn't the one that just slid
off fireworks looking over and I was
like okie dokie nothing birding just
keep on walking and then dum-dum I was
with his like Steve Steve I don't think
I was like no names Mildred and I called
her Mildred just in case the fuzz ever
they'd be looking for a Stephen a
Mildred do you ever do so when you were
a kid where you know you did something
bad and then you like ask somebody what
the punishment would be like I one time
I wrote on my door I was like hey mom
when I was to like I don't know what age
I was so let's say I was ten when I did
it let's say when I was seven did I know
how to spell stupid or whatever word it
was whatever I run on the door but just
so I can kind of like feel my way or
what the punishment yeah I get I'd be
able to get out what I could outweigh
get away with it like I would imagine
you calling coffee like hey I think
somebody lit a firework and it hit a
tree obviously good nice Samaritan yeah
calling it in well please hurry I think
next year you know we did a special
episode for moms yeah or just me and you
talked then we did special one for
guides I think next year on the fourth
hit shall I I want to just do a
fireworks episode ooh because i have so
many stories but it wasn't too long was
just mmm I don't think Jackson Jackson
was not born yet but run is easy and I
we run into trouble with the law with
some fireworks cuz the fourth of July's
his birthday happy belated birthday
buddy so but the police were very cool
and understanding they didn't break
balls but then also that was a different
time this was like six years ago oh yeah
seven years ago and the droughts pretty
bad and if they were the worst feeling
in life is messing up being stupid like
you're not up that's why when i say i
give everybody a break what i did last
night was stupid okay and the worst
feeling would have been if it did start
a fire yeah and you're just like oh god
how dumb can i get i was speaking what
did you see that one firework with the
bootleg fireworks video on youtube I
don't think so oh no is the one who sent
me yeah where the guy oh yeah cuz i know
that feeling that I had that feeling
last night the worst feelings are like
oh sweet Jesus
I don't want to start a fire then wreck
oh my god this is awesome I didn't start
a fire we almost did it was so much fun
cuz I guide that feeling in China when I
went off the fireworks a little bit last
night but that's what made this video so
funny for me cuz the guys like oh oh my
god oh my goodness cuz he didn't want to
start a fire and then when he realized
he didn't he was happy and he was like
that was awesome that was awesome then
he turns around he's like oh my god I
started a fire again oh Jesus so funny
so let's give craft coffee that plug
their craft coffee calm and if you guys
use the code word and it's very funny
code word it's good times bag I'll see
if they can change it the body bag for
the future cuz it's booked anything with
bag is funny cuz I'm 11 years old so if
somebody was to touch your good times
peg it's only 399 how great is that dude
so great and it's really delicious
coffee and you know what you work your
ass off have a little treat good times
bag why not it's great way to start your
morning that'll never not be funny
always funny I found out I farted in my
sleep Paula told me like what Robin
Williams said his wife didn't Good Will
Hunting oh yeah i forgot about that and
I like that I didn't it wasn't I didn't
wake up she just told me this morning
she's like hey so last night I woke up
for a second and then you farted and it
was I couldn't help but laugh always fun
it's still gonna be fun it's gonna be
funny to me I think it's only gonna get
funnier when I have kids that's
hysterical yeah I can't wait to have
kids do you ever a fart machine uh no we
had a fart machine and we would put it
under my dad's chair and I'm sure he
knew but just seeing him react look it
wasn't me it wasn't me Hey look it cuz
we it was a woman one of the ones with
the remote so it's like a bomb that's
your better whoopee cushion so that's so
funny I think I think they still make
them she get them for the office we just
need toys in here having fun is so much
fun it's fun to have fun speaking of fun
Tuesday night was fun it really was and
we're gonna share that with the world
right now right
lutely guys you I'll give Roddy the man
needs no introduction but will have his
website and Twitter frozen on the back
side of this he's so funny um and I'm
just so honored to know this gentleman
but I can't believe my friend I know
that it's so cool and you know what's
even more awesomer I don't know why I'm
doing this today it's kid stuff you're
shaking your head back at work yes I am
um so I was at the gym today and guess
who guess who was working out right next
to me Hulk Hogan no Roddy some cult who
is wrestling and I'm probably he's going
to be up in ventura next Sunday
wrestling so I think I'm gonna try to
get down to San Diego early this week do
the shows with me and Gabe on Friday do
my shows on Saturday and then drive back
saturday night so then I can sleep in my
own bed drive up to ventura on sunday
try that pizza place i've been hearing
so much about watch pro wrestling oh god
that sounds fun is he is he good look is
he fun to watch we'll find out me and
I'll be the first time I get to see even
see them yet so cool I know he knows
karate and stuff in real life how long
says in trope in 26 minutes oh my God
we're so long all right guys this is our
first live podcast I'm sorry we talked
so long in the beginning I love you guys
hang out with my pal Roddy Piper right
here
good night everybody enjoy the show is
gonna be great I'm on Instagram and
Twitter during quarter Steve's the ball
one more time for the party starter mr.
Darin Carter alright guys real quick I'm
this I'm not gonna make a big deal about
about children's hospital needs blood
and up so keep that in mind it's kids
need help alright so now we're going to
get ready to do they do I'm sorry hey
you got all right awesome so I'm so
excited that you guys are a part of this
we're gonna do a live this is my first
live podcast ever so thank you guys for
coming out I hope you're having fun
don't forget pizza the little juices and
now we're going to introduce the first
guest of the first ever live podcast
ever a gentleman that doesn't need any
introduction so I'm going to get
everything set up we have a little video
so you guys will know what it is and
I'll get out of the way and then now
we're going to start recording so have
fun
I chew bubblegum and kick ass and a ball
audible
the lamp froggies
they got dancers I take the question big
body little tiny really brings I was
body before rounding that's cool
robots
you
the mania closure from Glasgow Scotland
when 238 pounds the hot rod Rowdy Roddy
Piper
this is the best thanks you're hanging
out roddy how cool is this you got it
eat before he met me he didn't like to
hug anybody sure I would go over and hug
him because he didn't like it you sure i
got toy she she you got that on but if
you don't do it right you end up like
this if the shirt says villain for
people listening at home Oh doing a
podcast yeah we're good at there you go
how are you hello Roddy how are you you
realize that sir there you go now I
heard your birthday yeah wow how old are
you how old are you I'm a grown up no
you don't ever do that how old are you
now 42 haha I can't say that not laughs
you're beautiful so that one's wearing
out I got you one here also signature
edition
that's so cool that's right off the
press set yeah holy cow push okay no so
this is what we're gonna try to do just
pretend like we're all just hanging out
like we're hanging out in my basement
were 11 years old again and we're just
everybody's got a pizza and uncle
rotties coming over to tell us awesome
stories right sorry awesome stories
about Giants and mad dogs and guys that
had super flying powers oh he was a
giant how big was Andre the Giant like
legit he's hold this I don't know me see
um for those at home hanging from the
rafters I bet you he'd be up here
someplace baby with the air maybe even
up here there's a nail there that really
would have pissed him off I saw the
giant you pissed off one time only well
you know stories are he's at this bar &
Gill kikin ability to observe the
obvious on my pie right okay so andre's
at a bar and it was like he's football
guys NFL guys and they came in the bar
whatever and I like one of they will be
we're trying to insult Andre okay and
like you know like they want to pick a
fight with like hell proves that there's
some thoughts concussion things when
dumbasses
and would that happen often Roddy that
no there's the only time I've ever seen
it happen other than when he was laying
on my little skinny-ass he and as it and
finally calm down and as they left I
don't know what it was what I got napkin
paper copper some because the bars like
this and you go up there and there's the
door and there's the valet so that the
car is waiting and they come and they
like chuck some and it hits the back
Andre today through something that Andre
the Giant's head just so like I would
never do I don't care how drunk I was no
but I really notice how many more words
I put in it up I'm dead so what you
doing what they don't know specialty is
one step of andre's is three steps of
ours that's awesome need-to-know
information there and those boys got
down there in their car and that Andre
got up paintball and he got down and his
whole head right in a squat and he
looked at him and those guys were
slamming up the lock things and hold on
that I'm not kidding you now this giant
and turned their car over awesome you
gotta hide the giant or don't want to
get in trouble where do you hide a giant
come on you big bastard laughing yeah oh
did you remember the first time you met
Bob scheme just oh ok the cops came yeah
what do you think yeah he was in Texas
and uh like hey what out in your car huh
Jon Kaiman turn it over all right
everybody turn around put your hands
behind your back
awesome that's awesome oh yeah man cuz
like Andre he was special yeah every oh
man this is pretty inside yes yeah it
becomes like there's always there's a
line of honor and respect and if you're
going to accomplish anything there's
just some things you don't do it's what
you do when no one's looking at you that
makes you who you are niggering and like
my business the ground foundation I have
an oath and I'll never break but as
things have evolved the people thought i
would show i love you all so much you
gave me four kids and wife 32 years
thank you i love you and my wife and i
never once have talked about for murder
get er done
so I'll share this one with you it goes
against my better but because of
evolution you're starting to understand
this it's really it's really hard to do
what those guys to 330 times a year and
keep a family like those guys and
they're for real they're for real but ok
not tell you them stupid story i'll make
a quick so on to the jail of him wrestle
me yeah and he wasn't paid by the pound
you know backdrop my ass you know you're
falling a long way when you got time to
think haha huh [__] up your timing a
bad word bad word huh hey but message
your tiny now could you know hello have
a drink in a cocktail um what even Julie
each time cuz Andre the Giant had to
move constantly if he was stayed in one
place you'd watch him once twice but
then after that like you've got no
opponents you wouldn't pay any money so
he had to move and Vince McMahon's
senior book to you and he come into all
these different territories that were
broken down and nobody knew how to
wrestle the Giant and he come in and
slap him around and it becomes a bit of
a cart a little bit of a cartoon well I
was raised by the last the gorgeous
george guys you know yeah we just don't
have fleeing us we would like to have
fleas on but um it just passed the gay
rights thing I I wish I was gay I'd be
so damn Richmond not on Titan towers
stop that last part take that last part
always yeah
you don't know how much heat that's
gonna get me I was choking all right so
and what Andre would do for seems like
reach over to take my t-shirt off me put
it on himself look like the baby Huey
walking around with a teacher all right
I got you but he was a secret like it's
a psychology about Andre needed to know
that you understood he was hurt for him
to get hurt hmm so guys would come up
and hit him in the chest is to be and
every time Andre would hit him they
beautifly so I by being taught from that
where you don't you don't hit him fly
your stand a fight what Andre needed was
this I get up to my elbows in his hair
man and when he hit me i fried dough but
I just hang on like riding a bull all
right honey here we go and I come right
for those eyes boom I could believe in
me again and we'd be riding and butt and
finally I pay her the big bastard out
just with me but I was hanging on and
he's get his ass sat in a second
turnbuckle alright that's cool work
because he inside his soul his real self
yeah thinks that he has done enough to
earn your respect he won't pretend for
you if it's not even within the realm of
you know so he won't do a bad movie in
charge you he won't but here that's his
way of saying hey folks okay I'm a giant
this is why you're gonna remember me and
as long as I was on his eyes and I and
I'd be on him and if he hit me I guess
I'd fall down but I was very fast and
right back up on that giant okay I
worked many territories and every
territory oh-ho-ho balls licking me so
I'm us to wrestle them
I don't know 50 other times Wow one time
in Madison Square Garden God did this
forgive me for this one they look like
nice people stop drinking stop swearing
now telling the truth this really sucks
this is the best night ever you've gone
so there's David Schultz I don't know
doctor doctor dad yeah he's a out of his
mind yeah I was ten feet away when he
starts lapsed Ozil you know why that was
stassi's fault and I don't even like
your Schultz but that was styles fault
because stars I had one of his I don't
see Goonies you know I was in the
Goonies but anyway hahaha delivers a
time was second-in-command to Schultz
and was trying to interview him and star
so had that attitude are all these phony
wrestlers kind of thing and so as
Schultz when he he's shut him down man
again he shut them down stops was
sitting like let me do this you know huh
yeah all right boom Stossel comes you
know his wrestling fake Paul new bench
well your mama think about Paul me Oh
[__] yeah yeah and then he soon said he
heard trains trains anyway um just so I
want to explain for some of the kids are
like stas old dr. death Oh in the 1980s
a reporter for a twenty20 news magazine
show called 2020 tried to do an exposé
saying that pro wrestling was fake so
there was a guy that was a legit became
a bounty hunter after pro wrestling
right doctor yeah so he smacked the guy
in the ear the guy dropped them ensued
suit the rest well I whatever it what
he's being an [__] yep that's the
point yeah
can't sue for being an [__] make him
hear trains yeah that's the best Oh baby
Jesus so um I saw like Schultz and I
weren't getting along head to that and
um sugar oh oh that's pretty okay um
snooker we did a game and snooker was on
fire so there was this tag team match it
was dr. Schultz and myself and mass
square garden against Jimmy Snuka and
Andre the Giant Wow good he gave me some
warning Reagan Giants you know I'm gonna
wrestle the joinery to me more than a
giant does this is so good I'm not sure
if you know this but Jimmy Snuka ain't
that wild about me either still picking
coconut all of us we were gonna have to
look at to that will get that you're
getting a picture of rod being a very
lonely guy and Andre the Giant read the
situation before we're going to the ring
under the giant Rhett read the situation
of what's going down i'm not getting
along with Schultz were all bobbing for
the best buy ah Jimmy Snuka he was a him
Hogan and Andre Andre except John star I
John Studd really pissed him off because
jon said he was real giant that was a
bad interview uh-huh the Key says well I
don't have a DD I just got a lot to say
in different departments
ha ha ha um Jesus saw hard for me man
just get it done it's now I'm not
looking for an impact just maybe for
respect on because i had put my heart 50
times whatever it was with Andre the
Giant him being a man of honor in our
business he came to me and we figured
out and I had a foreign object in my
pants just let that one just sick always
running boy yes and open mouth insert
foot you know Andre Andre giant knew
that I was going to take out this piece
of metal and just you know get to Zed
here the end of the sea thank you um
we're in the ring going back and forth
and I took this piece of metal out and I
plowed that giant and that giant started
bleeding real blood all the particulars
are irrelevant for those you know how I
here's a good one like all the dirt
sheets you got out there i'm not a big
fan of those I'm trying to be okay guys
but I can't the very first WrestleMania
I'm on the airplane with Don Muraco and
here's tire magazine he's reading it to
mia says look and read this time
magazine says pro wrestling is
ninety-nine percent fake where Appa
looks at me and says see they don't even
know
and because as any carried are trying to
carry the giant out on a stretcher
mm-hmm first time ever ever and that was
his way of paying me back for all the
damn t-shirts I bought him that's
respect and it's a time when I needed it
and he knew it yeah yeah he's abused a
good giant but he could have been a mean
giant I tell you he'd be a hard guy to
move he didn't wanna get out the coach
now I have we could talk about what
everyone you know what one of my
favorite stories is that I would love
love love if you could do us the honor
and you told it once or twice at the
comedy store when we were hanging out a
lot was about driving along with Mad Dog
Vachon and when you were a young
wrestler yeah and when he sort of
showing you the road you know that story
about mel's diner I love him so much
it's so pure he is so pure ah jeez have
a dumb questions well I uh I started
progressing really young and my first
match I I never seen a pro wrestling
magic I was living in a youth hostel you
know to get to the chase here I'll
because the you thought was YMCA I just
wrestled amateur and had a knack for it
boom somebody just didn't show up and I
Winnipeg arena I don't really know why
they didn't my coach said hey I get 25
bucks you want to fight this guy oh the
car hostile was a quarter a night 25
bucks you know i'm in fremont how bad
could it be
so I went to my pipe band said what we
do my pipe and said we'll play and so
they had to kill on the killed with a
pipe band like in 15 or brain a bag
price commuter on boom and here we come
to the ring and haha you ever mr.
perfect yeah I loved it so much there's
so many stories I could tell you what
are you wearing try to stay on topic a
rut and the guy my pipe band played me
and I didn't understand the concept of
upstaging just yet did I learn quick
here because it was just like sawdust
and [__] her stuff around and so here I
come and the guy I find was mr.
Perfect's dad Larry the acts handing
320-pound Nordic Viking no natural and
steam now that he sees the entrance
coming out of his ear his opponent
wasn't there you know he just lost a
World title there I am 167 pounds my
nuts haven't dropped yet and I'm going
to go against this guy here 15 year old
kid if it's done 15 is a diet anyway
y'all bell went ding you know Merricat
ding ten seconds I includes one two
three she's so terrible the natural my
ass huh and so like I come back but he
busted my nose in my split man my
eyebrow and you know how they're in the
blood losing my eyes but I i saw the
promoter coming at penny loafers huh I
don't know why that's really important I
guess that's all I saw I thought I
thought he was going to cheat me out of
my 2 bits and buddy had the 25 bucks and
he said hey kid I think into this kid
you did great how'd you like to go to
Kansas City Larry henan gonna be there
no and like okay and there was one
wrestler left and his new promoter says
kid needs a ride no I'm just sitting
there you know
I got beat I was supposed to be the
tough got it down home I bagpiper guys
are gone and I but I can feel the
presence to my left hand side for
sitting this way would be to my left
that's how much I remember how much of a
market made on me and he was a Frenchman
I'm sionary [__] it's not
nighttime yet you stupid cops a girl you
need ride yes sir honey right please
cook supper comedic are we get our
outdoor go I'm grateful for the right
it's the price of admission that's
bothering me a little bit yeah hey this
guy he hated me because he passed like
the gorgeous george times and and he was
he was one Liam in England Commonwealth
wrestling champion and I he was he's one
of the most feared street fighters ever
around he taught me how to pull an eye
out you can take you to tell you know I
saw the drink okay I was gonna do the
three stooges move I didn't know tough
guy below me I didn't do that but it's
true you doesn't got boulders island you
know and eyes got four legged of tendons
we've become one here here here here and
you got to get behind the eye and it's
like an elastic band and you gotta snap
it or it'll just eat and there's four of
them for you know so you gotta be really
mad take an eye on FB least after the
two snap sorry my bad you know party fun
I know at some point there's gonna be
two nine-year-olds listening to this
like awesome i'll try to take Here I am
no don't try to sit up don't do that so
all the way so I'm driving with this guy
he all his name is mad dog vachon hair
all over him except on top of his head
yeah I'd like teeth missing here so he
could get your jugglers oh man he's like
ferocious okay and we're going down the
road um like if thats am radio and um
Scott it's like a longest commercial for
aluminum siding I've ever heard and he
drives never he parks at a hundred he
just met Doug an aluminum side and if
you want Luminum siding for your carcass
of a lumen siding because it keeps it
warm it's a not even the water drains
out all openings I didn't look I'm
hearing this show on woman siding for an
hour no he hasn't looked at me hasn't
tried to talk i think early i tried to
see how are you God sucker and stupid I
wasn't you he pulls over there's a diner
that's cool go get out he goes you come
in five minutes cook supper five minutes
after Tom mad dog cuz he doesn't even
want to be seen with me cuz I don't look
the part anna i get home i gave it six
just making it up I don't really
remember I didn't have the watch you
know one Mississippi two two Mississippi
why I come in and he's on the stools up
to the thing I Majella thing we get fed
in and like we speak a different
language called Connie and I know he
just like and he tells me a carny him
can't get away from him not a problem
and I'm down here and but by this time
he's ordered salad and steak and other
words that start with S vegetables
and he's got this meal or not like maybe
then that dog was mad because he's
hungry I don't know but when the lady
came to me she like I got 25 bucks but
it's Canadian and we're in America so I
got no money and the lady says would you
like something up crime class water
please man thought that song heard that
I a must have been his favorite charity
can you order little boy other little
scrawny little boy you hungry la ah I'm
gonna get a little boy something for
give him what down that dog has and all
the sudden flow starts bringing this
salad this steak vegetables vegetables
they help me out here and we're talking
and he's just full of personality
bipolar thing he was just hungry and
booming he and he's talking to me about
the war and how he was over here and
made bulletin threw him over to Germany
I guess to make him kill him or whatever
for Raja frère Jacques are you back
let's keep it coming and I love lemon
pie and flow a caller flow girl I don't
know i said i don't know how this
happened but flows got a piece of lemon
pie awakens pardon the waitress right
yeah the bleachers I just needed to give
her a name well I didn't know flow so
and I pull my hand out and I get the
lemon pie and methylation you cook
sucker you take on mag dump you take
advantage of me now you [__] and
he grabbed me by the throat and he
slammed me up with the tri-tip on his
little had red and foamy [__] none of
his Mountain colistin the guy doesn't
one he and boom had a heart attack I'm
thinking oh my ass die old bastard he's
my ride
so you know and then like got another
personality change a good [__] get
them my dog two dogs but talk yeah they
they call an ambulance and everything
[__] dumb dogs the point to make
it fun so I get there he wanted him ass
heavy guys to give him and I opened the
door and thrown in and form and slam the
door Reuters ankle which you know got
another C word phone went in and started
the car okay and those freeway and Phil
here we go in like you know hospital
side I'm looking for the Hoffman I'm
while I could drive like [__] I've been
stealing cars since I driving fool but
all of a sudden mad dog like the like
the Undertaker mad dog sits up pulls
down the visor takes all the
alka-seltzer out of his mouth pulls the
map out circles that were the diner was
that's just how he got a free meal hot
something haha civ is that the greatest
so great not if you were there it wasn't
ugly hahaha and then you get a chance to
use the lemon pie haha true story well
now in like we got a cold girl someone
goes [__] sucker I'm in yeah be right
there so cool gay marriages
I got nothing you have so many stories I
know I love no one you would when you
told me about your leather jacket the
different compartments in that I don't
know if we want to share that but how do
you let the different rules for
different things i'm sure there's that
these just things off the top of my head
i think everybody would love I know
you're sick of telling it but the
coconut story maybe that but then and I
really would if we have the time I want
to see them born I'm kind of Judge I'm
going on you tell you of you guys
getting sad man i'm told i'm bringing it
up or I'm out I want you to be happy I
love you too I honestly dude honestly do
we love you you've been my life I well I
don't have a whole I was i just moved
around and I then I got into this
business is but Dean so like I you all
know some stranger's I'm more
comfortable in front of a camera 93,000
people live that I am in a party of five
yeah I don't understand it I never
wanted to be I never asked for it zero
training other than in lunch cops up her
hahaha I suppose that story we don't
have to worry about the language anymore
huh
uh well there's a lady there by yeah
okay I autistic Thunder hey josh is
perfect oh yeah beautiful so okay well
where you want whole did talk about okay
don't look want the story I don't if you
want to tell but it was about you and
Little League with cold you want to tell
haha i think that's a mile try to get
family here sure that we don't we can
your coat of stucco whatever you wanted
a good nose when como maybe she like you
know jack in there it's jacket here is
made from your special oh thank you sir
the sunglasses oh my god it get you put
them on you see sure i'll be honest with
ya I'm damned if I'm gonna make you one
side give someone my sunglasses they
don't want am I let it alone now upset
if million stories oh man oh just a
really messed-up life in a good way so
call cake Holt Colts my son he's my best
friend he's my best friend when
something goes wrong they don't gold
because cold says he speaks dad um so
like I'm trying to I'll come off the
road I was about inch and a half taller
and about I'm about 20 to right now so I
my best way around to 32 to 37 I
couldn't get tired I go hours couldn't
get I she's annum but when I come off
the road it's a different world scuze me
all right there Bell the truth of the
matter is you know it is by the way
there's a teach it when you come out of
wrestling school which I've never been
to one however I might be obvious I've
never been in one they you should be
able to have a match with a broomstick
if you can have a match with a
broomstick then you're the real deal Wow
so with all this abstract knowledge I
come on
and I'm pretty rough you know but I'm
Jen I'm a gentle man I don't believe I
hate violence I hate it in the home I
don't believe in any of it i'm just i'm
an on or that merit position i don't
cares for I stand by the silent those
little people killing themselves it's
because of being bullied and I so just
out there I'm not telling these stories
to go to school be cool you know all
right and beating up people you know I
never missed youth I never fight unless
I have to for my family but or if I'm
getting paid I don't think I know who I
don't want to fight they go ahead and
think of what ever you want so I come
back off the road and colts literally
coke goes to the school he'd be like
it's like well how old when they first
start just pass the ball like 56 years
old I may be the only one I've given 780
maybe even nine ish and soho farmington
view ha elementary school and they got
they got the cute little farmington view
orange t-shirts on and looking for into
the orange bandana lol flare I guess
we're Farmington hbu you know and
they're so beautiful Bambi's you know
and they got a complaint away and they
get to the inning and they get to the
baseball field and just so you see there
and i'll show you how much I know about
sports so I Morocco Norton are in a room
it's a sunday afternoon and there in one
room and I'm in my room but there's the
door George I attend the doors open even
my dad my dad my mom I my father so uh
I've been hear him in there and I'm
doing whatever I'm doing his son who
kind of racking down and and I hear you
know there wasn't football and like
Baylor it's touchdown and then it's
going on but I'm in the other room you
know and I'm Baylor interception rather
by Baylor and I swear to god this is
true that it was so much since area you
know I don't know [__] I come back in
there there's more aqua Norton I got at
baylor's a hell of a player huh
hahahaha Baylor's the college team we're
gonna come check it out they said okay
hahaha that's how much I don't watch
sports I'm a wife's dream that way I'll
play them all that saw it comes there a
game away from home and these kids
they're the other team they got the
whole baseball and God bless them you
know but the thing with the straps and
that the cleats you know the stuff in
the hats and you know they're like five
fathers all right I got the infield take
it better on it's like you know the game
starts at six oh I don't know the rules
you know about I'm watching out from
afar cuz I don't want to embarrass cold
you know and i'm watching and and these
guys that's the team and they got all
the kids with me you know the kids are
just you know for my guys my son and the
coach was a good man just like and it's
like one minute 26 right oh you can have
the field up there so they started
playing they're all gone hole in the pre
better team and blowing the hitting
hitting finding our team gets up and
they brought him on get on get on i got
this whole thing going on outside
finally I had that's enough of that you
know and I come on down and I said to
the college because the coach pitch to
his own team would you mind if I pitched
thank you very much like a pin hi I'm
the picture how you doing bud all right
you ready here comes now um chew here we
go bud three good job get on base get on
base attaboy ball okay I was trying to
get the ball okay so you're making sure
you could get hit I was made getting the
field even how hard some Zach
no I wanna you know one of the many
issues I have is like if I get focused
in on something I I don't know when to
retreat hmm [__] me uh you know I'm
pitching and finally our own coach comes
and says hi Millie my Christian name is
tues says uh mr. tooms if you get any
closer to them you'll be handing them
the ball anyway I love that that's what
happened yeah have you ever been hurt
like you wouldn't want to do that to
nobody not worth if this jacket was made
for me it's a language jacket Bruce
Springsteen has one name just named drop
their pinball I didn't want to tell you
Janet Jackson does too this is the best
it's like Tourette's I can't help go
[__] yourself in room the five yards
just last WrestleMania Bobby Orton's
down the stairs again I think it's time
maybe whatever it's a billionaire list
and Bobby's going down it and Vince
McMahon number 23 well Bobby scissor
yeah they paid she says I it says here
that Vince McMahon is number 23
billionaire in the world just don't you
think you want to try to get along with
them now
hello WrestleMania out here from initial
23 I actually love Vince man i do uh was
a talking about his dad is Jack so I'm
back in he'd get in trouble but they
they wanted you to because it made the
paper and I was expendable there was no
I didn't have a number until I was like
19 I got me a social security number so
I could pay taxes like to thank you for
that yeah greatest country in the world
and yeah baby its biggest country in the
world sure but when they caught me they
threw me in jail and we had a bad shot
in fresno one time I don't know if
you're ready for that what is okay so
yeah I just want to summit thanks the
promoters would encourage you to get
into trouble is what you're saying cuz
it would make the papers sell more
tickets this is an era before sports
entertainment wrestle people paid to see
unfortunately the heels get beat up and
Cheer the good guys and they wanted to
see real fights and the more real fights
you got into outside of the ring the
more they knew you were serious business
inside of the ring you could be cold
nation so there we are I see that's what
Cole does and like I can't get it I
don't know why I can I speak dad just
like Oh
thank you so much holy cow are we
talking about your jacket thanks so ah
well now I get it you know then they had
to go and bail me out of jail and stuff
and it was time consuming and a budget
restraint so they had this jacket made
and because I got stabbed bunch times um
it's got Kevlar in it she can't stab me
and over here you back in those days is
it's not bad it's just like we all carry
guns and this is the rule like if you
had a gun that was like a revolver the
first hole was empty in case with a pin
amer so the pin doesn't hit it and hurt
somebody second one we had was a blank
so from boom you know everybody should
be gone the ones that aren't gone I got
four I'm trying to give you a chance
work with me 7000 pro fights and you
pick my ass to fight bad day and so just
to get it down cuz you know I carry my
cell phone here now but I that that was
for all things that need to be taken
care of right away this was for cash or
put in for cash this one life is in this
one this one here pocket zips and it's
got my passport in it and yeah I ain't
[__] you and I'm just second now
just get in there all right cuz then i
put it back and then I'm there and this
one has a stash pocket but I won't leave
it at that
and um uh yeah so if I got in trouble I
could just run and get on the airplane
goal and I have everything it's like my
purse and that's why this guy and its
really really heavy one of my wallet my
green card stuffs in there Wow sweaty
and everything is awesome yeah there you
go James bud made it work the veteran
best night ever ah yeah that's why the
jagged so cool who's me so you don't
have to pack up anything just grab the
jacket young as he go huh I'm out of
there you know Mike Hill was under my
arm she's gay bashing I don't know about
gay bashing but when you come in in 1969
with a kilt on hmm it was a tough road
tell me I'll be dressing room one time
huh coming into a dressing room one time
and and like I was early because I was
nervous and I come in and there's nobody
in a dressing room because he's not
supposed to be but all of a sudden when
i get to the top the door with soph into
the bathroom and as this manager named
ken rainy used to manage the interns is
jacking off you know
I'm just a messenger here so I guess
it's you know it's supposed to be rib or
something and I had this a rib though
like isn't it supposed to be somebody
there to enjoy funny kind of thing
anyway oh she's you know they started
doing that kind of [__] to me for a
while and then Lord Alfred Hayes yea big
Schwantz on my good man and huh and he
he come in the shower and he chased me
with his penis with a rudder Roger haha
the [__] radhe radhe haha I'm not
[__] at all I'm not [__] it all
we're gonna tell he's sweet could you
tell the story about the promoter that
like the smoke cigars ah wrestlers
revenge haha so there's this place and
uh holy [__] man the placings place in
salem and it's just a little old theater
and underneath is just it's just like
dirt and pillars and it's not a real
terrestrial is that and there's a table
and the way they let your showers after
the show is finished you could use the
hot dog water to shower and I can see
what it was and like when you win the
promoter page when the promoter page you
know the old-timers if they like you
they tipped you off if it didn't like
you doing but he'd start paying and he
put like a roll of quarters you know in
your hand and you're watching and he put
like a five and if you smile at all he
quit but if you learned not to smile he
might be able get like maybe 25 bucks 20
bucks match you know um and he always
was drunk and annika a two page look
like a poodle rocio his name is Alton
Nolen as name is Elton Owen and uh you
know I guess yeah
Annie you're the same suit on the be
[__] sleeps in your logs puffing a
cigar hey are you bunch up a side
there's a wave coming dressing room
there's like chairs around you know and
there's one table there for Jim big a
lot of old-timers played a lot of cards
man lost a lot of money and uh my tag
partner his name was killer Brooks and
he was from waxahachie texas man killer
Brooks was great friggin partner man I
love him and he was gutsy LOL well moons
watching yeah and you know save him
didn't drug because this guy didn't do
[__] ah gosh you guys couldn't drop
flies to [__] nice to see you too you
know NE te sketches the the baby face of
the main event back yeah yeah and he
puts us a guard on he goes back there
and like it's just it's so rude and
stuffing yeah I don't know man it's like
having a [__] eulogy yes [__] hand
circular Brooke Smith we're all looking
at this poor guy got like three kids you
know he's getting twenty bucks 2050
imagine being in the end the real days
they used to have professional drivers
like the midcard guys and you'd pay them
like a penny a mile to penny a mile I
remember three penny a mile and I got up
in the air and make they would take it
and you give me a change sometimes their
wife would make sandwiches that saw them
for fifty cents you know giving this guy
a high time and we were all younger and
you know we see them then finally kill
if Brooks got up come up to that bench
yeah them spandex kind of like pullovers
and took them spandex pulled over his
pulled him down air all over them
took that cigar you looked at that cigar
and rolled it around he put that cigar
up his ass and he was in no hurry they
married didn't bother killer Brooks
outfit because he wanted to make sure oh
there was a definite and his timing was
impeccable ah he went put that cigar on
there no fear that this guy's gonna see
him pulled up his pants she's down next
to me ten wrestlers hahaha just waiting
waiting what's [__] guy man skyman
and he's just like he's drinking
straight out of the bottle and he turns
around like this big shot writing his
poor man he comes balcony he's that guy
the table was on his left hand side he
comes to see we wouldn't know that [__]
and you were there Davis on the left n
say here's the door and you all he's
scrumble in scales ha ha he picks up
that cigar hey I thought you guys did on
time another thing [__] dying we're
dying hahahaha I love it he's no trigger
is any good on another tirade old blood
you know you're gonna bleed damn it
bleed on the floor you're ruining my
[__] camera tires on mouth not [__]
you know ok tire something out any
finish and then he turned
and you open the door they put her she
garden his mouth and he turned around
and he walked out the door and he got
half a step I swear I swear to you okay
he turned around over the door took a
cigar eyes and another thing it smells
like [__] stevie wonder nobody dared
make a sound one for the good guys
awesome Harod we only have about five
minutes left that's how fast this flew
by I'm sorry but maybe we could just
take a question from somebody so because
you're suddenly awesome people viewers
Joshua what would your question be great
question Josh great question Joshua Mary
he's the best Oh appreciate this time it
was a one quick shake I should probably
tell them first time Steve introduced me
to him at the comic store and we shook
hands and I'm a very anxious person and
I thought and I said out loud to you am
I are we shaking hands for towing and
you said to me I'll let you know
just dig under kill him oh no you can't
write that you're beautiful your view
right question I told you thing about
doctors about best part of my job today
no um ask the doctor one time what's the
best part of your job he said delivering
babies best part of my job and I
there'll be an autograph flying two
hours whatever and the best I've done
this five generations in the same family
Wow but watching you and watching you
with your dad and your dad and your
sister your mom whoever and the bonding
that you did around I thought if he was
under the lassie you'd be cheering for
Lassie it's just too so much love and
they they they strong lucky you know
they tremble and they cry and I so do I
and sometimes they just need a hug you
know I can go into a hospital and put a
smile on a little boy's face when a
doctor can but the doctor can fix them
so we need everybody to pitch you and
that's what you are you're beautiful
Dusty Rhodes Dusty Rhodes was a national
treasure was the national treasures hard
to go was like full ah yeah I don't
think that they knew how good he was he
did one interview we're in TBS were
important solely and he had a poster
made by some children of a school that
he had visited and it was a minute
interview and Dusty Rhodes came in and
he put this poster down and TV and he
put a chair down and looked at it and he
didn't say a damn word and I don't know
i'll be making that like 40 seconds into
the interview 45 just akhir came down
his eye and just as before it ended he
said I love you too wow that he's
communicating on a different in a
different way you know we won't get too
much into this but I haha but dusty rose
in the funks and Dick Murdoch and all
the guys they were [__] ass crazy all
very fun haha who's this guy Bobby
Jagger's he lied about everything I got
a ranch I got a bigger one he wore a
pink cowboy hat in Amarillo Texas
there's the function they had a flash
flood and under this bridge it was just
total body that was renting Bobby
Jagger's was running a a corvette
stingray and the CB thing back there
yeah put the hammer down or whatever the
heck it is you know and Terry Funk it
already crosses it's flooded you know
Bobby Jagger's hey come on back there
Barry booming well tarifa put the hammer
down and that Bobby Jagger's drove into
that bullcrap pull of water to follow my
god and the sunk is just [__] son
oh my god is supposed to be looking out
for he did Jonah into the floodwater and
there's good cats there's beer cans
flooded another thing that came up from
the car holy [__] hi so dusty roads and
deke Murdoch what I dick even her ducks
in the ring you know and there's a tag
team and I don't know some give me a
name of baseball player Mike Schmidt
works good haha did sir the Dickey
murder out he's visiting and Schmidt he
doesn't know this but Smith draws like
an orange from the 26 rollin like hits
Dickie perfect boom but dick he thought
it was a partner the other guy and boom
and took the bump and went over the ring
Oh awesome all right I love you thank
you so much for doing this
I love you too the greatest love you so
much ladies and gentlemen Rowdy Roddy
Piper thank you guys so much for coming
out the hot rod roddy piper Thank You
nerdmelt thank you all you bodies thanks
for coming out good night and God bless
you I have something for you guys here
we show everybody on the way outs going
to get a treat bag for hanging out
tonight so there you go good night and
God bless you guys
we're good times gone so guys that was
the live podcast we did with rowdy roddy
piper and i wish you guys were there but
since you weren't there or maybe some
summer you are mmm i wanted to share
that with you and my buddy Bryce said
put this together with nerdmelt already
wants to do another one so that's
exciting lady you know what we're gonna
be up in Toronto yeah you're coming with
me I am we're gonna be there the 13th to
the 15th and i know i have august right
yeah so it's like a month away it is
like a month holy moly that's so soon
you're doing friday and saturday i
believe at the comedy bar okay I can I
mean IIIi think that's it that makes
sense and then I'm doing as of right now
only saturday evening a podcasting
seminar but I'm also looking to get
alive find your video oh that would be
incredible be really fun um yeah and I
that's what i think is you're doing
friday and saturday at the comedy bar
okay it's gonna be great it'll be it'll
be so much fun this poutine we're one a
blue jays game Oh God trying out there I
brought their innate ians I did dawn my
rare as podcasts how was it I was
nervous cuz he's like a big celebrity to
me and he's like not only that he's like
one of them I think he's like one of the
best comedians of all time but he's nice
he's so nice nice to me yeah yes he's a
nicest person ever but on his podcast i
gave i said at how much i love Canada
and it was Derek in tirana that brought
me to hasn't even in gear yet every
wasn't I first time mm-hmm was last
August I remember oh wow so I did uh
yeah Toronto this will be my second time
Toronto been the cavalry twice I've been
to Edmonton the Canadians are good
people I really do I really can't wait
to go up there so nice and the girls are
so pretty they are I've heard that yeah
and nice and then there's like the
Niagara Falls is that close I don't even
know Niagara Falls slowly I turned inch
by inch that's the three stooges I don't
know really mm-hmm there was a really
good i think that was in there episode
called woman haters I love the three
stooges Niagara Falls slowly it was so
good i bought their box and I meant to
watch it i can i come over watch a Three
Stooges
I love the three stupid 10 discs said i
just bought like last I think was less
black friday because that's like that's
my thing now I just go in at like two in
the morning you know agostino don't got
to really hmm I'm gonna wait in line I
don't really have anything that I need
that desperately but I'll go in and be
like hmm any good deals like a capital S
on best buy the best oh I wanted to give
a shout out to my buddy Edward Vega in
Florida I have a special surprise coming
your way buddy so stay strong and I got
something coming for you I also wanted I
found the website for the people that do
the t-shirts and stickers is so cool i
NK ad co.com in God co yeah incat cocom
we got our buddies craft coffee Don
Carlos taco shop eat a burrito what kind
of gonna try the chili rate-rigging yeah
i think so i'm gonna try to eat pretty
clean for the next couple days so i can
go down there and just kill it that's
the best thing you eat healthy just in
preparation for yeah you know what I've
been doing more cardio I've been
following your lead and this is my
secret what do you do go to youtube and
I type an Army Ranger running cadence
where it's like your laugh you'll laugh
your laughs right laughs that stuff and
you have it on repeat no did you can get
like listen like 30 of them in a row
that's really smart it keeps you going
keep you motivated now it's the best
it's so good and I pretend I'm an army
man and I just keep on running that's so
cool heads I didn't even know they had
that yeah cuz i had bought them but my
crappy um computer crashed and i lost
all my music but i had i had awesome
ones i had army ranger Navy Seal and US
Marine running things that if it was
yeah and I'll keep it going it's amazing
so that's my new uh fun for the summer
so I think I'm gonna get down a la jolla
early hopefully just run on the beach
just to push ups and eat burritos and
some comedy but I'm almost thinking like
if I could get a job at Children's
Hospital and just do the podcast I would
do that in in la jolla or up here i had
any children's hospital on down there
yes and i wanted to say that when you
said
in the intro if you don't live in LA I'm
sure every children's hospital ok blood
go figure out how to get involved I'll
tell you what guys the secret to life is
helping other people so however you do
that and I know we have a lot of parents
that listen trust me you're helping
other people like a part of the reason
why I know I have time to volunteer and
stuff like that settle have kids so all
the dads out there thank you so much for
sharing this podcast I do want to say
this and this is something I think we
should talk about at the beginning of
the next intro number 1 i'm so grateful
of all the people that are sharing my
stand-up comedy album remember this with
their family I saw that video you posted
Oh with the little kids yeah adorable
right it was pretty like two brothers in
the backseat yeah they loved it and
they're little they're like real little
guys I gotta get this children's book
done that's where I belong anyways so
the podcast sometimes things get a
little more adult here than in my comedy
act but I think what's cool is that
parents listen to this and then they see
if their kids can listen to it and it
reminds me of the the adult
conversations I would listen into from
the top of the steps so I hope I hope
that's what it is for you guys I like a
cool uncle Steve so I want want people
to be happy I hope you guys are enjoying
your summer um Lee thank you so much for
all your help everybody that came out
tuesday special shout-out to Rowdy Roddy
Piper Bryce Smith neck Goldberg darin
carter the party starter mr. Lee sayat
autistic thunder all my buddies they
came out especially my buddy art that
brought his mom for her birthday the
greatest I was on brought their mom yeah
for a birthday so cool art and Daniel
they're my buddies I ran into them at
WrestleMania we're supposed to be best
friends it's the best this really is
most i could keep on talking forever
let's just end this episode people like
dude I got work to do all right I love
you guys have a great week take care and
god bless
you
yesterday was such an easy
hi
you